l'actualité de ce 11 avril c'est aussi
le député UMP de la troisième
circonscription des Yvelines inorigénaux
qui fait l'objet d'une enquête
préliminaire après la plante de l'Union
Syndicale des Magistrats l'ancienne
plume de Nicolas Sarkozy lorsque ce
dernier était président avait noté avec
estimé que le juge Jean-Michel Gentilly
avait déshonoré un homme les
institutions la justice en mettant en
examen l'ex chef de l'État pour abus de
faiblesse à l'encontre de Liliane
Bettencourt plus précisément la plainte
porte sur l'outrage à magistrat et le
discrédit jeté sur une décision de
justice d'effet passible de
respectivement un an de prison 15000
euros d'amende et de six mois de prison
et 7500 euros d'amende reste à savoir si
l'immunité parlementaire d'origano peut
s'appliquer le principal intéressé n'a
pas encore réagi